[Musique]
oddo et jus oui la vie belle
elle est jolie c'est que de la joie et
souviens toi qu'il ya des filles qui ne
pensent qu'à trouve rire les mois et sur
leurs lèvres
tu trouves le parfum de la féliciter
mais le temps passe
en
venir enfants
brown
on est encore en train de guetter oui je
guette maman à travers la fenêtre c'est
même pas vrai mamie elle attend que son
mec vienne la chercher c'est tout toi tu
la fermes
ce serait quand même bien que vos
parents arrivent maintenant le dîner
presque prêt bon attention
va-t'en frodo tu vas te prendre des
bouts de verre dans les pattes a brisé
sa porte show papa tu es une vraie
calamité maman elle est née à ses
décorations à la regarde moi au nom
c'était sa boule préférées ouais c'était
sa boule préféré quand est-ce qu'on
bouffe gènes de ces dames 1
il arrive samedi sont là
allez on sent les valises à l'est
et les valises et oui ça fait du bien on
regarde moi ça la fameuse date de la
mort est bien vu je me suis dit c'est
bientôt noël alors c'est gentil alors
certains sports c'était extraordinaire
oui je dois dire mission accomplie c'est
vrai une mission où on va tout vous dire
vous allez adorer ce qu'on a découvert
c'est un camping qu'on a acheté way
camping en camping ou ça à la campagne
on s'installe dans le midi rien à
bouffer dans cette baraque minable un ça
va pas du tout c'est un grand garçon
comme toi c'est un besoin de protéines à
son âge
ciré pas et moi non plus franchement
vous auriez pu prévenir avant de décider
un truc pareil
ouais depuis quand doit-on demander
votre autorisation et voilà ton père est
contrarié et alors vous pouviez nous
consultent et non une famille ça
fonctionne en démocratie nous aussi on
existe il est prévu pour quand cette
opération tampines sauvage mais très
bientôt après les fêtes de noël ward
quoi si je me jette de la tour eiffel ce
sera votre for cément fermer
définitivement dans ma chambre au nom de
main c'est la fête de l'école
[Musique]
je ne savais pas qu'il avait une copine
aweys ensemble regarde ça paraît évident
pas supporter un truc pareil ça y est tu
tombes dans le mélodrame jeunes des plus
le revoir
et toi non plus
mais de quoi tu parles je m'en vais pour
toujours je demande à charmer oéa c'est
de monter sur scène
vous allez assister à une performance
qui déchire profit du web
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des tristes non non ça va qu'est ce que
tu as j'ai un peu froid c'est gentil je
voulais te faire une bonne impression
mais je me suis rendu ridicule en dirait
suis très bien
non je suis ridicule il part en péter
les plombs
tu sais ce qui leur prend ils veulent
qu'on parte à la campagne comme dans ses
émissions stupides a affirmé ses
émissions débiles les gens croient
qu'ils vont être heureux ailleurs mais
c'est toujours un échec sont pas plus
heureux du tout ouais c'est clair
mes parents viennent d'acheter un
camping près d'un petit village dans le
sud de la france au camping si génial on
va couper tous les ans dans le sud où ça
jamais au même endroit on part toujours
au hasard on se retrouvera peut-être qui
sait ça serait une coïncidence
approche tout âge et j'ai un peu froid
partez quand le jour de l'an j'ai même
pas le temps de dire au revoir à mes
amis du mot revoir alors
[Musique]
ok maintenant charles va vous dire un
mot j'espère que vous avez aimé la
performance parce que pour moi c'était
la dernière
je suis dégoûté c'est tout ce que je
peux dire charles
qu'est ce qu'un chat à tandis qu'yves à
pioncer rien tu sais wisa non elle doit
être dehors mais pourquoi vous partez
charles usa on s'arrache
attendez moi je veux savoir si vous
déménagez
allez on rentre tant qu'on a encore une
baraque salut is a way d'accord tu sors
avec ce looser maintenant est alors toi
je t'ai jamais vu avec la moindre 6
exact je suis pas trop à l'amour mois
[Musique]
attendez
ça c'est pour toi
voilà
une webcam on pourra se parler en visuel
et si tu sors avec une jolie fermière on
pourra la voir aussi à l'écran et en
profiter un charles l'isaf et pages
tapée de lima
ouais soit pas timide fait lui un bisou
salut ciao ciao liga bonne route
ciao un petit dernier pour la route
ouais tiens ça ok et m ciao à vigo où je
suis content d'avoir vendu ce trou perdu
il devenu trop vieux pour ce travail a
chez sois pas triste ça va aller tu
pourras venir me voir à marseille
sois pas triste je suis pas triste théo
marseille c'est pas le bout du monde 1 6
7 cm frodo et où est passé ton père
j'aurais aimé lui dire au revoir quand
même je crois qu'il doit encore un livre
et une armoire
ok bon allez j'y vais au revoir au war
prodon
au revoir
et françois ne tend pas trop flou
il a besoin de toi
adieu
[Musique]
c'est sympa le meeting le pays des
cigales en regarde moi ces jolies
boutiques là c'est pittoresque que non
oui
ça y est ça y est on arrive
voilà notre nouveau joyau le site
parfait pour un camping le soleil le
paysage les bords de mer on va gagner
une fortune à réussir c'est un vrai
petit paradis pas vrai les enfants
regarder ça
[Musique]
oui
quoi ce temps pourri il plaît peu cher
et peu chères bravo vous avez déjà
l'accent du midi à ces magnifiques
vous allez vous plaire ici franchement
c'est un très bel endroit
1 je vois je vais capturé ce moment
historique
il sert écrit avec deux beaux sourires à
lecci hommage en faut que j'aille aux
toilettes
c'est vraiment immonde vous appelle ça
des toilettes mais nous allons les
remettre en état
ils ont pas encore inventé le papier
plus la porte est foutu tout est foutu
ici ma chérie sinon on n'aurait jamais
pu se payer
voilà c'est la salle à manger
ah ouais c'est cool n'y a pas grand
chose à faire
non pas tant que ça un petit coup de
neuf
la cuisine est en parfait état et tu va
engager une grosse équipe
personne ta mère et moi on va tout faire
nous-mêmes on est obligé on peut pas se
lancer dans des frais ratha vu ça nous
voici dans notre nouvelle maison
mais c'est une catastrophe
on s'attaque d'abord aux campings après
on verra et on va dormir ou en attendant
tiens regarde danser mignonne petite
cabane à vous verrez c'est charmant
mon vieux frodo on est trempés de
partout enfin faire
[Musique]
non
viens on gère
n'ayez pas peur nous les méridionaux
nous sommes le peuple de l'amour voilà
ta classe jeune amant courage à puce je
vous le laisse oui entendu nous ne
sommes pas comme les gens du nord ils
sont souvent froid est coincé vous
trouvez pas très jolie réputation
nous y sommes la voilà enfin
bonjour mademoiselle je peux connaître
la raison de votre retard j'avais juste
besoin de faire un brin de toilette
et alors vous l'avez jamais c'est la
sleza fin j'en passe qui est drôle à
porto moi aussi je pourrais rire c'est
facile de se moquer de quelqu'un qui
vient d'ailleurs
mais ça m'est égal je veux pas rester
dans cette école je vous déteste tous un
peu le respect envers les professeurs
étaient sud
[Musique]
je peux te parler cinq minutes on est
dans la même classe
tu as l'air plus âgées c'est parce
qu'ils m'ont fait redoubler on y
retourne
j'aurais tendance à la barre j'ai été
complètement ridicule les élèves se sont
moqués de ton accent si tous ces ou qui
ont un accent je m'appelle jules isa
comment ça c'est que toi t'as pas
d'accent en fait j'ai grandi en ville
toi aussi tu es parents ont déménagé
ouais enfin ma mère est morte
un accident de voiture il ya longtemps
non ya un an ça a dû être dur sûrement
plus dur qu'une vive dans un camping en
p nk ans tu vis dans le camping et c'est
cool c'est un endroit formidable on
parle pas dit même à mon avis souvent je
tenais un petit coup de main à l'ancien
propriétaire
je le faisais de l'argent de poche alors
là c'est pas mon père qui me donnerait
du fric pour travailler avec lui
ou est ce que tu vis dans le village
évidemment être d'accord mais à quelle
adresse belle envie là je te dis
pourquoi c'est pas important l'adresse
tu as raison c'est sans importance toute
façon je serais parti dans un mois
[Musique]
j'en ai ras-le-bol de cuisiner tout le
temps je verrai les concerts ce bien
meilleure que chez nous
[Musique]
allez tomber tu te sur feuilles mortes
alors ce sera un goût bizarre une
spécialité de la région
[Musique]
les peignant mais nous aider
moi c'est moi renchérit
[Musique]
oh
et roméo
enfin si tu as toujours sale gueule moi
est ce que tu peux venir m'aider s'il te
plaît j'y arrive pas avec le four a pas
maintenant je prépare à manger demande à
isa de faire la tambouille visa visa
qu'est ce que tu veux s'te plaît tu peux
venir m'aider un peu
il doit revoir la méthode de la
dissertation alors là on a également des
achats ou s'il peut venir
charles qui fait je suis occupé je peux
pas aller bien
il pourrait se bouger un peu
si c'est annabelle elle nous fait des
crises de larmes depuis que vous êtes
parti à ça doit être à cause de toi mon
amour je m'approche actuellement de la
jolie fiancée afin qu'elle puisse elle
même parlé à notre pays sans l'adoption
bonjour à la belle allée facility
quelque chose à ton fusée peut faire
pareil mais c'est vrai tu veux dire le
frère et la soeur
il a manqué charles aussi dans sa chasse
[Musique]
est vrai bien marché c'est bon mais non
mais c'est pas moi je les répare et
pourtant j'en ai assez j'en ai c'est pas
possible
personne n'a sorti que ça cramé et
maintenant agacera les photos
j'en ai vraiment marre
[Musique]
j'en peux plus si c'est ça ton idée de
la cuisine provençale qui fera fuir les
uns y tournera pas d'invités ça c'est
clair
même moi j'en mangerai pas ça suffit
comme ça c'est pas trop tôt je ne
supporte plus d'être ici c'est normal
pourrez-vous bosser comme des bêtes vous
n'avez pas un moment à vous et aux osé
joli ici quel endroit fantastique
ça fait combien de temps qu'on n'a pas
fait un repas normal regardez moi cette
pâtée pour chiens des bois des boîtes
combien de temps ça va durer la comédie
du bonheur ah oui mais toi tu parles tu
parles tu pourrais m'aider aussi et
c'est pas moi qui ai demandé à venir ici
vous nous avaient embarqué dans votre
cauchemar
j'en ai marre de vivre ici je veux
retourner chez nous
alléluia n'a ne pleure pas s'il te plait
je ne supporte pas ça oui moi y'a pas
votre autre chose que je ne supporte
plus à commencer par tout ce bazar
montage on fait nos bagages et wise as
c'est pas ma faute si c'est le bazar
dans cette baraque dit tais toi tu peux
pas arrêter de l'ouvrir un peu c'est
toujours mieux d'ouvrir des boîtes de
conserves tu crois pas c'est carrément à
l'ouest main au sud
[Musique]
je
c'est ancien ouais c'est frodo il
s'appelle frodo je suis désolé qu'il ait
plus de faire peur commenté entrée
j'avais encore les clés et pourquoi tu
es venu ici je crois que il ya un lit
quelque part tu t'es fait jeter de
tétouan ouais c'est ça avec les parents
c'est dur impossible de s'entendre c'est
vraiment l'enfer d'enfer c'est les
autres
c'est ce que disait sartre un philosophe
engagé je connais pas quand ma mère est
morte j'ai cru que j'étais foutu
tu pense souvent à elle tu m'étonnes
t'as pas peur de l'oublier des fois ci
moi ya un garçon dans ma ville c'est mon
amoureux depuis assez longtemps
j'ai presque oublier presque oublié son
visage ces dames
j'ai l'impression que je m'éloigne de
lui j'ai toujours son image en tête mais
elle devient de plus en plus floue comme
un fantôme un fantôme
oui un fantôme j'appelle ça comme ça un
fantôme c'est mignon
et toi quoi t'es amoureux
ouais je suis amoureux mais elle veut
pas de moi ton is here ouais je sais il
s'appelle commentons fantôme
justin il l'obtient c'est un secret
isa maman t'a préparé un petit des
années
jeune homme bonjour euh oui j'ai oublié
de te prévenir c'est mon ami jules il
est dans ma classe et il travaillait au
camping avec l'ancien propriétaire
comment il s'appelait déjà sur wii
pipière il voudrait savoir si par hasard
t'aurais pas un petit boulot à lui
proposer pourquoi pas
[Musique]
charles la mairie
tout est petit pourquoi t'es unis si je
suis venu cuisine et j'ai appris que
vous étiez tous bords de faim je n'ai
pas supporté l'idée pour travaille très
dur il faut bien branché surtout quand
on est jeune et oui la démolition le
nettoyage planter les clous faire de la
peinture
oui c'est déjà très dur pour vos parents
et en plus vous vous êtes obligés
d'aller à l'école tous les jours pour
apprendre les matières les plus
difficiles elle j'ai l'impression que tu
es en train de te moquer de moi la roma
chéri j'ai du respect la façon dont vous
aidez vos parents c'est magnifique
je suis venu nourrir deux jeunes gens
dont le courage est exemplaire et j'ai
même décidé vaud l'ibook de mettre
toutes mes économies dans ce camping tu
devrais pas à momie et pour quelles
raisons tu vas tout perdre
je préfère perdre toutes mes économies
plutôt que de voir vos pauvres parents
ruiner
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu dirais de faire une
discothèque dans cet endroit où tu rêves
mon fils pour une discothèque il faut
des tas de permis je suis sûr que ça
aurait du succès y a pas un seul endroit
pour danser dans la région ce genre de
permis ça demande du temps et de
l'argent
alors si je comprends bien ça vous plaît
pas on dirait que vous n'avez rien mangé
depuis des vous savez les gens dans le
sud y mange pas et boivent toute la
journée du ballon charles pas de
generali ouais enfin de toute façon ils
sont au bar toute la journée et jules
comment dans le coin on dit comment on
dit et ce soir je vais mettre une tôle
ce soir j'ai envie de me péter la gueule
comment on appelle un ivrogne à un
alcoolo alors un alcoolique il faut que
je rentre
qu'est ce qu'ils lâchent pas
graf
allez
ciao
[Musique]
non
et aux photos
[Musique]
et là mon cher
où
c'est la dernière fois que je
t'accompagne j'en ai rien à faire de ce
camping la peur qu'il n'y ait pas de
filles à draguer exactement que des
familles de bouffe avec leurs marmailles
insupportable qu'est ce que t'en pense
bernard tu te ferai pas une gonzesse toi
aussi aux remorques tu t'en fous tu as
tes potes gillet nona bon alors on bouge
je crève de chaud dans cette voiture
j'ai cuit pendant tout le voyage les
reconditionner marche pas évidemment tu
n'as pas fait réparer je commence à en
avoir marre à l'essor de l'aïe prend le
volant s'il te plaît sandra calme-toi un
peu je te dis tout de suite que si je
sors de la voiture c'est pour retourner
à la maison avec les enfants
s'il te plaît papa vas-y conduit on est
presque arrivé
[Musique]
vous avez vu ça ils ont même changé
c'est quoi ce nom timbuktu
[Musique]
ah le sol est trop dur je t'avais dit
qu'ici c'est pas un bon endroit je
n'arrive même pas à planter m'ont piquée
avec moi c'est toujours la même chose on
n'a jamais le bon emplacement à temps
c'est quand même pas la première fois
que je porte une tente
nonna bernard alors ouais aller et moi
[Rires]
alors ça y est on se retrouve
ouais il en vache mans transformé ici
ouais mais il faut que je m'habitue
quand même est ce que t'as vu c'est qui
cette fille gilles bernard von arx
salut je
vous connaissez isa c'est la fille du
nouveau propriétaire
salut salut salut je vais aider mon père
a monté la tente
ça fait un bon voyage
j'ai les toits mes parents s'engagent
sans arrêt toi ça va mourir moi ça va
bien la journée là d'accord disparaît je
veux plus te voir
[Musique]
je vais à la grotte
frodo où est ton m
va chercher
cherchari
[Musique]
c'est toi eh bah ouais c'est moi sa
patte dormir dans une grotte ça me
dirait bien tu parles après une nuit tu
serais dégoûté et tu fais ça souvent tu
rigoles ou quoi
je suis pas dingue tu dis la vérité à
ton pote ben évidemment chez j'ai dormi
ici par hasard en fait hier soir j'étais
un peu bourré j'ai pas eu envie de
rentrer à la maison
ouais je comprends merci si sympa trop
cool la gratte serait le plus important
c'est la première impression ce touriste
il doit sentir l'endroit être à l'aise
il doit se dire je ne veux plus partir
d'ici ce camping c'est le paradis sur
terre vous êtes le propriétaire de
tombouctou timbuktu c'est pas un camping
ça tu as tu iras minable sur lequel des
péquenots ont planté quelques tentes
alors vous représentez la concurrence or
la concurrence mais ils font pas le
poids en face de moi on est bien seul au
sommet quand on est le meilleur
j'ai l'argent pour acheter tout ce que
je veux ça je vais prendre ça pour
commencer je pense truc là aussi pour
l'ensemble du mobilier là tout ça et ça
aussi bien sûr je sais que les plus
belles pièces sont dans la maison de
l'antiquaire je peux ainsi en essais
privés là
attendez désolé aïe aïe aïe j'avais
raison j'avais raison jamais réseau ah
je vois ce que c'est monsieur est un
connaisseur
donnez moi ça exactement enlever ce
biais que je veux c'est lui là non il
n'est pas avant mais bien sûr qu'il est
à vendre
en tant qu'anti coeur vous en trouverez
facilement un autre et puis mon fric
vous permettra d'entretenir votre amour
de la dive bouteille
je viens de vous le dire il n'est pas à
vendre
un huissier a saisi les vols non mais
j'ai tout vendu
oh non pas le vaisselier quand même le
client m'en a offert un très bon prix
mais pourquoi tu l'a vendu c'était un
cadeau pour maman tu sais qu'elle
adorait ce meuble mais c'est vrai mais
dans la vie on peut pas toujours garder
ce qu'on aime le vaisselier de maman tu
avais pas le droit de faire ça c'est
comme si tu vends des une partie de son
âme d'un maire n'est plus là jules elle
vit encore dans mes souvenirs
oui mais les souvenirs sont illusoires
ils passent comme des nuages
elle est là et ça c'était son meuble
écoute j'ai chargé tous les articles
dans le camion et j'irai les livres et
moi même demain matin mais j'en fais
toujours
non j'en fais alors c'est ça c'est
vraiment que l'argent qui t'intéresse ça
c'est avec ça qu'on fait le café
cafetière de maman t'as qu'à la vendre
aussi pourquoi pas près par mois une
tasse me sentirai mieux
ouais bon aller à plus tard salut
fraudeurs
[Applaudissements]
tu viens avec moi non il faut que je
travaille qui achètent le café à ton
avis
t'inquiète pas tout ça ça va changer on
va gagner beaucoup plus d'argent
dorénavant
je peux prendre frodo avec moi tu vas
encore tout sous les noms c'est décidé
j'arrête l'alcool tu crois plus écoute
chiffres au dos et là je boirai pas ta
ma parole ça marche
d'accord allez frodo pas dans la voiture
allait
[Musique]
jules ouais elle est belle couleur ta
chambre
j'en sais rien et jamais regardé away
qu'est ce que c'est que ce genre de
réponse tu évites toujours la question
est est à copine n'est pas ma copine
mais tu voudrais bien aller sonner
devismes devine à l'ére est très content
d'eux ils ne résistent pas tu sais que
les garçons sont les plus forts en toi
tu en esclaves à l'iran toi cl tout
fantôme at a failli deviner
la visa tu dois venir et des grands
mères je dois d'abord me laver visage
cet endroit vraiment beaucoup changé en
un an
et je parle pas seulement de la déconne
ona et si on allait nager ensemble
carrément alors on se retrouve à la
riviera 2 heures oui
cher antiquaires ou devrait on faire une
petite réduction d'accord je vous fais
1500 euros de reduc si vous payez
comptant au hockey 2000 4000 5000 le
conti voilà merci beaucoup
il faut encore me descendre ce
vaisselier il rentre avec moi mais j'ai
payé pour la voir la réduction que je
vous ai fait ça correspond exactement à
son prix de vente mais il est à moi ses
souliers sauf que tout n'est pas à
vendre mais ma parole mais cette rentrée
[Musique]
bonjour ya la fraude au mais tu vas
obéir oui allez viens frodon ici c'est
rien c'est mon cher vous n'êtes pas
laisser avoir
qu'est ce qui vous fait dire une chose
pareille j'ai vu que votre client
essayer de vous rouler en fait oui c'est
vrai que votre mari essayait mon mari
dardan cl sa femme
arthur est mon patron je m'occupe de ses
chevaux si j'étais lui je vous aurez
choisie vous c'est pas mon genre ouais
c'est évident
[Musique]
boutique était tellement ringard un mode
paysage c'est clair que ça fait paysanne
votre père sera sûrement d'accord pour
faire un tour à new york ah ouais c'est
super l'amérique c'est la pch voudrait
vie je lis ça quand même tu t'emballes
pour n'importe quel chiffon
[Musique]
maman tu leur territoire est pas
maintenant
non
où et fraude aux way
je conduisais et puis il ya une voiture
qui est arrivé dans l'autre sens est
arrivé à toute vitesse
alors j'ai dû faire une manoeuvre pour
l'éviter j'ai heurté le parapet de plein
fouet et le vaisselier tombé dans le
ravin le vaisselier mais tu l'avais
vendus oui c'est vrai jules je l'avais
vendus mais quand j'ai vu ta tête j'ai
voulu le récupérer pour tourette ça tu
devais encore complètement bourré ou et
fraude aux d'abord j'y reviens plus du
tout mais j'en sais rien je me souviens
pas très bien je sais plus si faux dont
étaient avec moi dans la voiture ou non
c'était où tous a dit waouh ça s'est
passé je m'en souviens pas je me
souviens absolument de rien ah oui c'est
trop facile ça mais je te préviens si
jamais il est arrivé quelque chose à
frodo je veux plus jamais être voir
mais là
les
salut
salut jules m'a dit que tu viens ici
depuis des années vous êtes plutôt
proches ouais plus tôt
et tu trouves qu'il a changé et pourquoi
est ce qu'il aurait changé
il a quand même perdu sa mère de toute
façon c'est pas tes affaires
tu trouves pas que ça bien joli ici moi
je préférais avant pourtant on a tout
améliorée je parlais de l'ancien proprio
c'est pas très sympa tu apprécies pas
mes parents alors je parlais pas de tes
parents si tu veux savoir
puis je comprends mieux
non merci
[Musique]
monsieur oui voyez pas vu mon chien
voilà je n'ai pas vu
monsieur vous n'auriez pas vu mon chien
est chez vous voyez pas fait mouche 1
non allez voir au fus à huy le refuge ok
merci et tu viens il a une petite
croisière sa tante
julien 12 canaux et c'est papa qui le
look si ça plait il en achètera
plusieurs les affaires marchent on
dirait pas tant que ça il faut trouver
des trucs pour attirer les clients près
des canaux et ça va faire toute la
différence
[Musique]
c'est joli cet endroit
mais tu vois ce que je vois
[Musique]
ouah
qu'est ce que tu vois
c'est pas possible si c'est bien réel
[Musique]
mais enfin cet homme aurait pu mourir tu
sais très bien ce que papa a dit il faut
éviter la mauvaise publicité surtout
avant l'ouverture non-assistance à
personne en danger c'est un délice
on pourrait entendre est ce que vous a
donné la permission de traîner dans ma
propriété
on croyait que c'était un camping c'est
libre d'accès non oui après l'ouverture
mais c'est demain
vous êtes qui on est du camping timbuktu
nos parents sont les propriétaires s'ils
bloquent tout va c'est trop classe comme
non combien des toiles 3 il n'y a pas
beaucoup de monde qui voudra y passait
ses vacances dans en attendant on est
presque complet ça ne va pas durer mon
bonhomme je vous déclare la guerre et
que le meilleur des deux campings gagne
allez dehors les espions
[Musique]
isa leur camping il est génial timbuktu
a du souci à se faire
je parle comme un looser
[Musique]
oh non oui tu
frodon répond moi
et attention vous avez peur des chevaux
non mais vous n'auriez pas vu un chat
dans les parages
non j'ai perdu mon chien j'ai peur qu'il
ait eu un accident
de quoi ils alertent écrivait le mois il
a le poil belge il est plutôt frisé je
crois que je n'ai aperçu ce matin il
accompagner un homme avec une
camionnette rouge ça c'est mon père
c'est tout ce que je peux vous dire
j'espère que vous aller le retrouver
salut en plus j'aime pas beaucoup ce
genre de trucs pardon personne ne nous a
jamais parlé de cette concurrence
il ya un problème d'aménagement du
territoire ouais c'est possible j'irai à
la préfecture dès demain
oddo
comment
[Musique]
non ça j'ai trouvé frodo quoi
photo j'arrive
ça y est j'ai trouvé une grosse corps et
peut rejoindre gilles
[Musique]
donc
je suis là mon cher
voilà résibois
[Musique]
la fraude on est là il se comprend pas
comment il a fait pour se retrouver là
on l'a qui n'avait je crois alors je
sais qu'il l'a fait c'est cuit alors
fait un homme mal rasé avec une
camionnette rouge j'ai mémorisé sa
plaque d'immatriculation 8888 os 24
envoyez-moi une corde
allez-y doucement
[Musique]
pour chiens c'est bon
malheureusement en temps
john on y est
mus en ligne
attention il faut l'emmener chez le
vétérinaire et prévenir la police non
non on prévient pas la police mais jules
sept ans mathilde nappe est un chien qui
est pratiquement mort à la police tu as
compris si je ne veux pas un besoin dead
c'est urgent s'il vous plaît on a un
chien qui est gravement blessé ok un
jules tu peux monter dans la voiture
avec trop d'où tu viens avec vous merci
attention laissez passer
ne vous inquiétez pas je vais m'en
occuper allez c'est pas là je vais y
aller tout seul
d'accord
oumar les résultats au revoir oui je
peux vérifier si vous avez la bonne
adresse
et ça qu'elle nomme jules lafleur alors
kenz rue de la montagne à limeil et oui
c'est ça
merci il faut l'opérer de toute urgence
seulement il y a un problème encore de
factures à payer vous devait l'opérer
je n'ai plus que frodon je peux pas le
plaindre
[Musique]
le ménage n'a pas été fait depuis des
semaines
[Musique]
excuse moi pleurait
c'était wisa comment va frodo après
l'opération ça ira pour l'instant il
récupère à l'hosto jeu il va rester avec
nous parce que son père est en voyage il
est parti pour quelques jours
[Musique]
dans mes bras de ciani
le mas d'azil h mois qu'est ce que tu as
et bah je croyais qu'on devait se
retrouver hier pour aller nager et il
faut que je te montre ma chambre tu vas
voir d'accord enfin je sais pas les
garçons vont faire un break dance et je
voudrais pas manquer ça pardon mais je
vais rester avec elle et annabelle tu
vas pas me laisser
désolé mais non allez en soit plus tard
alors m'a suivi contente de revoir tes
amis c'est surtout les amis de charles
je vois est ce que papa est au courant
pour le camping paradiso d'après la loi
elle ne devrait pas exister pas pourquoi
il existe ça c'est la corruption
ils ont dû graisser la patte politique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mauvaise reste pas une minute de plus
ici encore un qui se cassent par tous
c'est bizarre non
ça va être un désert allait bien tout à
fait légale j'ai l'impression qu'ils
s'en vont à cause de nous ça n'a rien à
voir avec vous les gars c'est depuis que
le paradiso a ouvert conneries tu
paradiso papa c'est quoi le problème
mais franchement je ne vous le dis fais
pas du tout normal je peux pas passer
mon temps à surveiller mes enfants pour
repêcher qu'ils prennent des drogues
je suis en vacances ici et c'est un
rendez-vous pour toxicomanes coin des
drogues dans mon camping mais vous voyez
passer monde qui se défoncent mais ce
sont mes enfants dès que leurs amis ya
pas de drogue
vous avez l'air sacrément affaires les
deux jeunes filles nous ont dit que
c'est cette bande de voyous qui vendait
ce genre de saloperies déjà une vie
possible
je crois que c'est le moment de vous
montrer un truc alors c'est ça que tu
fais avec ta caméra obsédé
regardez c'est un petit peu plus loin
ouais là regardez bien ces les deux
filles du paradiso ouais tu les
espionnes exactes elles sont sexy
j'ai voulu les films et maintenant on a
la preuve de ce qu'elles ont fait quoi
elle raconte des bobards à tout le monde
on n'entend rien elles peuvent parler de
n'importe quoi d'après la réaction des
gens on dirait que c'est pas des bonnes
nouvelles les gens ont l'air choqué were
regarder ce tir qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
faire pour que les gens restent ici il
faudrait qu'on ait quelque chose que
paradiso n'aurait pas par exemple on
pourrait avoir une discothèque
on ne m'a pas banon les gens vont dire
que c'est un mythe toxicomanes
ouais mais c'est avec ça qu'on pourrait
les battre vous revenez encore à la
charge avec cette idée ridicule jusqu'au
risque à faire une discothèque et puis
c'est l'anniversaire dit ça c'est le
moment de faire la fête
je trouve que c'est une bonne idée super
on l'a fait cette discothèque ita
emballe pas j'ai déjà calculer le budget
c'est à voir
pas mal regarde alors c'est une affaire
qui roule
[Musique]
dans la boîte
bon
yanina
c'était madame ya personne
jules bonne aujourd'hui est ce que tu me
feras une démo de breakdance quand on
aura ouvert la discothèque
ça fait super longtemps que je t'ai pas
vu danser rappelle toi l'année dernière
tu avais fait un carton ne compte pas
là-dessus c'est bon je le fais pas la
tête
il ya d'autres garçons d'accord et
pourquoi pas toi
[Musique]
justin
mais qu'est ce que tu fais là je fais au
camping au camping paradiso je te
présente à nous qu elle c'est valérie on
a fait une discothèque tu veux venir
c'est une super idée c'est pour
l'anniversaire 10 à ton anniversaire
bien sûr je vais venir je m'en voudrais
de rater la fête d'une si jolie
princesse
on se voit demain 3 me
ce sera mon plus bel anniversaire dit ça
t'embête pas fini mais parfois même tu
vas voir
[Applaudissements]
le concernant
[Musique]
mise à cette camionnette
je la reconnais c'est le type qui a
balancé frodo dans le ravin à temps il
faut l'arrêter
non c'est ben ali c'est sa camionnette
quelques camionnettes
elle était pas du tout comme ça un agent
de police je veux produire toutes les
têtes ça ne fait pas sa voix pourquoi
cet homme est un mâle coliques
inutile de le harceler pour quelle
raison parce que c'est le père de jules
il est revenu de voyage
il n'est jamais parti en vrille âge
et toi tu m'as cacher ça
non
en otage tiens oui quoi une invitation
pour toi voilà une discothèque timbuktu
c'est impossible
ils n'ont pas les autorisations en
direction quant à eux c'était la seule
clause non négociable avec les autorités
via
on s'en va d'ici là mon père et moi on
se bagarre sans arrêt ce ne sont plus
des vacances à temps et ma soirée
discothèque
[Musique]
je viens de chercher on part à marseille
pour retrouver un de nos vieux amis à
mort le petit déjeuner là bonjour fraude
aux tab yens hormis le lol ouais non ce
téléphone y aura un radar des roches
m'énerve sa clinique vétérinaire
saint-hubert bonne jour bonjour à damas
et celle lafleur je voulais vous dire
que je viendrais chercher mon cher
frontaux aujourd'hui jules lafleur tu
pourras venir le chercher quand t'auras
pas été facturés aucun problème madame
et ça c'est de ma part mais je sais
c'est de la balle
rama souviennent plus de 6 à 12 heures
contre ça ça vienne ma chérie de gâter
ont tiré
[Musique]
juste la mythique scène lui frodo qu'est
ce que tu fais là bas ça lui donnera
[Musique]
été complètement guéri on dirait moi il
frodon et berri
mais jules est à l'hôpital clinique
vétérinaire facture opérations de fraude
au jeu
jules
gel
elle est passée au ras
annabelle je vais aller voir jules je
m'inquiète pour y mais la fête commence
dans cinq minutes je sais excuse moi et
puis tu m'excuseras aussi auprès des
autres est ce qu'on a pensé à tous les
boissons la musique les cacahuètes
qu'est ce qu'on peut trouver d'autres
dans une discothèque et les cigarettes
excusez moi vous pouvez pas rentrer
c'est réservé aux jeunes je cherche mon
fils jules il est là non non il est
parti mais qu'est ce que tu fous là
frodo
si franco est là alors je ne dois pas
être loin jules a eu un accident
il est à l'hôpital il est juste choqué
c'est pas grave
je veux le voir c'est peut-être pas une
très bonne idée
je vais à cet hôpital écoute moi bien
écoute bien je suis tout ce qu'il reste
genre wague ou non il faut que j'aille à
l'hôpital non il a ok des films et vous
rentrez avant minuit un look cendrillon
sinon c'est la citrouille ce soir même
les vilaines sorcières vont au bal si
pape a réussi son coup tu mens cet
endroit sera fermé à l'aube a relancé
plus baroque l'hôpital nord vous
comprenez pas c'est trop grave grave moi
bah en fait mon fils a eu un accident
eh bien je vous sens mettent à l'hôpital
remercie tous les cubains gorgé de ça je
vais faire le chauffeur d'accord ça va
aller voter
harry est dé quoi tomber locaux désolé
urgence
le ramène inquiète
bienvenue en timbuktu club pour la
soirée d'ouverture
mais chassez vous voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
annabelle et choix les filles du
paradiso tu peux me dire ou es romeo
chez pas où il est c'est sûr qu'il
n'était pas à l'intérieur c'est bon
steve s'occupe des blonds et annabelle
je vais mettre un pur son ça te dirait
de venir danser
désolé ça aux deux basses vallées bouche
tu les six à la billetterie et tu viens
charles lisa mais pas ici quoi elle est
avec jules et moi j'avais promis d'en
parler à personne
oh bah tant pis pour son
alors alors joyeux anniversaire merci tu
devrais pas être en train de danser suis
ici c'est normal tu l'as laissé et qui
tue sept aux fantômes je suis allé dans
ta chambre tu es allé chez moi alors tu
as vu mon père oui et il a réussi à
enchaîner des mots j'étais planqué en
fait
planqué où ça je m'étais caché dans
l'armoire
et puis il a failli me découvrir il a
pris une petite boîte et musique qu'ils
faisaient
[Musique]
je suis désolé cette mélodie me rend
triste
c'est la musique du film préféré de ma
mère mon père lui avait offert ses
boîtes à musique il m'avait offert une
âme aussi c'est juste une musique mais à
chaque fois ça me fait pleurer si tu
avais connu mes parents avant izard ces
deux là il sait mais plus que tout au
monde tu aurais dû voir ça
maintenant tu comprends pourquoi mon
père est alcoolique
tiens
je ne peux pas accepter c'est pour ton
anniversaire
[Musique]
faut que j'aille aux toilettes
arthur vous deviez m'emmener à l'hôpital
ah oui on va y aller vite
[Musique]
on le tient le patron du paradiso a
drogué le père de jules
j'ai tout filmé
je sais quand est ce qu'elle arrive il a
pourtant placé juste au courant il ait à
l'hôpital avec lui
super
des tristes non ça va c'est quoi ces
larmes
c'est une poussière que j'ai dans l'oeil
en fait tu as raison je suis super
triste
j'aurais jamais imaginé les vacances
comme ça ça va aller t'en fais pas non
ça va pas aller je me sens perdue et moi
mes parents sont insupportables ils
passent tout leur temps à se bagarrer
bien sûr toi tu t'en fiches devenu dans
ce camping pour votre visa de toute
façon comment te dire et ça l est
et les moins belle que toi c'est l'heure
du braille tech romeo est pas là alors
c'est toi qui le remplace c'est l'heure
du breakdance charles remplace romeo est
pêché voulait
c'est bon on continue dans la salle
non allez on s'en va c'est bientôt
l'heure il reste un quart d'heure
m
[Musique]
normal
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
t'aurais pas secrète qui m'a jamais dit
non moi si j'ai écrite
je suis amoureux de toi depuis toujours
il a et écoute
t'inquiète pas ça m'est égal
elle va alors le pochtron il fait quoi
là tu peux leur ont fait faire de mal
soleil se lève
qu'est-ce qui les grattes non pas la
batterie
allez
pas maintenant
[Musique]
santé ont fait part ici
[Applaudissements]
à
romain caméra s'te plaît
[Applaudissements]
attention
j'arrive à jouer
et pour tout pour tous avant d'adhérer
spécieux j'ai rien fait c'est un
pyromane lâchait murs isolés n'a rien
fait vous allez lâchez moi je peux le
prouver
j'irai à la pêche lisa elle est où ma
caméra
je les ai perdus tu blagues on peut la
retrouver
alors vous avez vraiment outrepasser les
lois vous aurez très vite un avis de
fermeture
comment un avis de fermeture de la
discothèque 92 tout le camping quoi mais
vous pouvez pas nous faire c'est enfin
madame vous le croyez pas que vous
pouvez ouvrir une discothèque comme ça
sentira sans autorisation attends je
pouvais pas dire à cette fille qui
paniquait aubin débrouille tout seul moi
je dois récupérer ma caméra
immédiatement qui peut brûler moi je
m'en fous ça regarde la caisse est vide
tu étais censé la surveiller mais tu as
préféré de barrer à l'hôpital tout ce
qui est arrivé ta faute au type un peu
gonflé me dire tu as charles les deux
filles du paradi's ont piqué l'argent
alors que tu étais censé les surveiller
et toi tu as choisi d'être à l'hôpital
écoute il fallait que j'aille le voir
oui mais ce n'était pas le moment la
discothèque était en train de brûler et
annabelle elle était là elle dansait
avec nous parce que romeo n'était pas là
il pourquoi romeo n'était pas là parce
que roméo film est le coupable
et toi tu as perdu ses preuves je ne
sais pas si j'ai tout filmé la batterie
est tombé en rade au moment où le
propriétaire du paradiso météo qui fait
toute une histoire pour rien pour rien
il n'y a plus d'argent je te signale que
tombouctou va fermer est-ce que tu
atteindre ça s'arrête
je vais te dire ce que j'intègre sais
que tu cherches à protéger un de tes
potes et ta petite amie alors que moi
qui m'en gueule comme une pompe petite
gamine qui me traite comme une
irresponsable le jour de mon
anniversaire
elle a un peu raison toi t'as pas été
très efficace n'importe quoi
je suis à l'hôpital
oui maman
mais qu'est ce que tu fais l'hôpital je
suis venu voir jules annonce n'est pas
l'heure des visites au règlement mais
pas avec ça écoute je prépare les
bagages tout le monde s'en va je reste
pas longtemps
j'arrive qu'est ce que c'est que ce à
quoi tout ton dessin là ça représente
quoi
nous anciens ouais mais je vois bien
mais ce sont des dessins érotiques va
non on a l'air gai t'es pas au bon mais
là dessus on dirait que tu aimes les
garçons on est juste amis tu es d'accord
avec ça bernard évidemment pourquoi ils
sont chouchoutés dessin regarde moi ça a
c'est dégueulasse
[Musique]
c'est berner
comment j'ai pu faire ça les regarde
j'ai honte de moi j'ai tout fait foi rim
qu'est ce que tu veux encore c'est
bizarre c'est toi vous êtes disputer
ouais c'était très bizarre
il avait l'air dévasté je jetais il est
amoureux de toi c'est évident quelle
bonne idée mais il va falloir qu'il
trouve quelqu'un d'autre l'amour entre
garçons c'est pas mon truc à moi tu sais
quoi bernard est troublée et c'est
normal tu es tellement mystérieux ah
ouais t'as trouvé ça tout seul et justin
hier soir elle était mystérieux ouais
c'est vrai justin même que j'ai dansé
toute la nuit dans les bras de ce garçon
formidable arrête
si je suis venu c'est j'ai de mauvaises
nouvelles
je mets en femmes et tabac droit de
partir comme ça ça va je me sens très
bien
[ __ ] et jeffrey charles
je veux qu'ils s'occupent de bernard
gelé senti trop mal tout à l'heure quand
bernard veut réfléchir il se réfugie
dans la grotte ça va mieux
jules j'ai voulu passer de voir à
l'hôpital mais ils m'ont pas laissé
sortir
moi je voulais plus de voir mais tu vois
je suis là écoute je suis dans les
problèmes jusqu'au cou et je me souviens
plus de rien j'arrive pas à comprendre
ce qui a bien pu se passer dans toute
cette histoire de dingue
rappelle-toi de l'accident avec frau
dont il faut que tu te souviennes des
détails c'est la meilleure façon de te
défendre
pour l'instant ils disent que tu as
perdu la mémoire ouais nan l'accident de
voiture c'est encore une autre histoire
je me suis cogné la tête et je me
souviens plus si flo était avec moi mais
un peu plus tard j'ai eu une image de la
voiture qui fonçait sur moi elle roulait
au milieu de la route
moi je roulais normalement alors j'ai
donné un coup de volant pour l'éviter
c'était un cabrio les bleus avec trois
femmes à l'intéressé surtout ça à peu
près oui elle ressembler à quoi c'est
ces trois femmes dans la bagnole la
femme qui conduisait
elle avait les cheveux blonds je crois
et elle avait sa paire de lunettes
posées dans les cheveux et sur le siège
arrière il y avait deux femmes plus
jeunes plants toutes les deux
[Musique]
écoute bien jules
j'ai revu ses deux filles sortir de la
voiture d'arthur le soir de la fête
intime bouquetot les fils d'arthur ouais
ouais elles ont même appelé papa écoute
on va prouver que t'es pas le coupable
on s'est même qui a provoqué l'incendié
seulement ça c'est un peu compliqué
bernard b à ba
meira
gérer pour moi berna
berlin
bernard où est ce que tu es planqué
charles charles
[Musique]
je tombais nous battons
tiens art and poor's
j'avais toujours in sur moi on est malin
ça va pas être facile d'aller là bas je
suis vraiment handicapé avec ses
béquilles t'es sûr que c'est un camping
ici ouais pourquoi ça ressemble pas à
timbuktu petit bourg tout c'est beaucoup
mieux
je me demande où ses filles ont caché ce
qu'elles nous ont piqué
ap
elle regarde qu'est ce que vous faites
là on adore les chevaux oui mais ça
c'est une voiture
oui aussi les voitures je vous reconnais
c'est pas vous qui avez perdu votre
votre chien oui ça vous l'avez retrouvé
alors un peu amoché mais ça va mieux
comment va votre père ça roule comment
ça ça roule
il est en prison pour quelque chose
qu'il n'a pas fait c'est terrible et
vous cherchez quoi au juste à
l'innocenter vous savez comment faire
on essaye de trouver une preuve
et vous la trouverez ici
voilà
les charles y avoir c'est les mêmes
desseins de la grotte de gier tu as vu
ses peintures sont des peintures
rupestres
c'est dingue c'est vachement joly c'est
hallucinant oui un jour elle avait volé
une trousse de maquillage et elle
l'avait caché dans le box del diablo
en tout cas c'est là que je les
retrouvais eldiablo ouais comme le
diable c'est ça ne faut surtout pas
énervé ce cheval il est capable de se
mettre en furie comme son maître le
patron du paradi's vient bien là mon bon
je vais devoir vous laisser il faut que
je donne une leçon et je suis déjà en
retard mais je vous souhaite vraiment de
trouver ce que vous cherchez
bonne chance au revoir je vais y aller
[Musique]
on n'arrête pas de tourner en rond
il faudrait trouver une issue ils
auraient dû mettre des flèches
c'est mal foutu c'est quand je connais
très bien l'architecte c'est pas un vrai
professionnel
quelle galère les portables passent pas
ici génial
[Applaudissements]
tu as trouvé oui je regarde
[Musique]
alors je sais moi charlie bernard ont
disparu pas moyen de les retrouver
j'ai envoyé plusieurs messages sur les
portables apparemment ils sont dans une
espèce de grottes du zéro et l'aisne
falloir attendre une seconde c'est
urgent gilles mais enfin on mais j'ai de
la visite on dirait la jeune fille de
timbuktu et vous vous êtes mon père est
toujours en prison pour quelque chose
que vous avez fait c'est une terrible
accusation ça excusez mon ami il est un
peu provocateur montrez moi ce que vous
cachez derrière votre dos mademoiselle
faites ce que je vous dis sinon je vais
énervé le diablo et franchement vous
risquez de passer un moment très
désagréable commence tout de suite je
vous les donne qu'est ce que tu fais
vous n'avez pas tout restituer par la
caméra isa non pas la caméra
non encore du matériel bon marché à a
ça va toi ouais
chez malo toyo chambre et j'ai la tête
qui explose
appuie toi sur moi je fais de la peine à
bernard je crois je me le pardonnerai
jamais tu as été choqué je me cherche
pas d'excusés mais je croyais être le
plus malheureux sur terre était arrivé
dans ma vie et toi dans la mine
ok plus que ça
[Musique]
on est là c'est alors on peut pas bouger
fier mon tableau bien aller qu'est ce
qui vous est arrivé ça va vous n'êtes
pas blessé vous voulez je vous emmène
quelque part oui à la police par exemple
sans la caméra c'est même pas la peine
et avec ça
ce soir
[Musique]
j'attends fraude ou non c'est le manque
d'oxygène alors ils sont tombés dans
cette grotte
c'est terriblement profond on voit pas
jusqu'où ça va
non quand je pense que bernard a
toujours peur du noir
je vais appeler la police
on a la preuve donnée
ouais
ça marche pas là monsieur
la qui prépare son coup vous voyez là
l' incendie c'est lui
qu'est ce que c'est et où deux jeunes
ont dégringolé dans une grotte inconnu
je vous envoie les secours on coule
j'aimerais bien filmé ça c'est un malade
quoi tu penses qu'à film était un malade
et alors je revends ça à la télé ouais
dans ce cas je te passe mon téléphone
est ce que l'image est bonne regarde
d'accord et poussez vous s'il vous plaît
monsieur vous comprenez pas chien il a
un super flers oui d'accord revient bien
à les membres pas de problème et comment
il s'appelle
il s'appelle frodo
s'il nous est arrivé quelque chose je ne
me le pardonnerai jamais on n'aurait
jamais dû venir dans la région c'était
beaucoup moins dangereux quand on était
en vie oui tu as probablement raison
nous allons bientôt quitter cet endroit
est retourné chez nous
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe allez venez et me
suivre un jose arrête emmène les filles
à la maison toute la nana la femme aussi
au ridicule
pour quelles raisons délit de fuite
après avoir provoqué un accident de
voiture à l'est à lundi tuez-moi frodo
est faux de revoir tu nous as retrouvé
inconscient
et ça va les gars personnes blessées non
vous attend la surface laissant aller
maintenant
[Musique]
merci
à
m
[Musique]
tu m'en vais pas de quoi aujourd'hui
france deux jeunes gens ont découvert
une grande priest ruse adolescents
français ont découvert une nouvelle
grotte de jeunes français a découvert
une grotte préhistorique dans le sud de
la france
les deux jeunes gens qui ont découvert
ce site préhistorique quand été sauvés
ils sont maintenant hors de danger à
proximité d'un ami qu'il y avait été
menacée de fermeture il ya quelque chose
mais il me connaît bien
ouais tu peux être fier c'est un bon
petit gars
[Musique]
courage pas je t'aime
merci de m'avoir accompagné
s'embrassent
à très bientôt
voilà je suis abonné
alors
[Musique]
oh
isa
nonna rentrer chez elle alors je vais
lui dire au revoir
est ce que tu vas revenir mais je sais
pas ça dépend de mes parents ça te
ferait plaisir que je revienne
évidemment
tu sais ce soir là quand j'étais avec
justin justin oui avec justin
il était pas avec isa elle était avec
toi à l'hosto tu sais elle est sympa il
elle m'a vu quand j'ai embrassé son mac
réellement n'a jamais voulu
et alors et bah alors j'ai compris que
ma vie était vide et que j'avais surtout
besoin d'affection et justin est très
gentil
désolé mais j'aime bien cette musique
pas de problème tu peux l'écouter
ça y est exc plus pleurer non puis
surtout après ce que nous n'a m'a dit
c'est bien que vous vous soyez
réconcilier tu as raison
comment vous allez faire pardon c'est un
amour longues distances pour toi aussi
j'ai pas d'amour longue distance alors
moi non plus
donna n'est pas ton fantôme mais alors
c'est qui ton fantôme quelqu'un qui ne
veut pas de moi il n'existe aucune fille
qui ne voudrait pas de toi parce que tu
es tellement
mais ça
novelli
depuis le premier jour je sais que je
t'aime et quand j'étais gens en colère à
l'école et quand on était ligotée dans
l'écurie
isa je suis heureux que tu existes
pourquoi tu m'a jamais rien dit parce
que je te voyais amoureuse je croyais
que le grand fantôme de ta vie c'était
juste un jusqu'à ce que noah me raconte
tout
elle t'a dit quoi que tu tiens pas tant
que ça arrive justin n'est qu'une ombre
comparé à toi je change de planète quand
tu es de planètes et de fantômes
[Musique]